what was the feeling at the end of the
of the screening yesterday an
extraordinary warmth and I think uh love
that was expressed all of this seemed to
come together in the room we haven't
been here I guess 76 76
taxi drivers yeah gratitude
that's really special as Marty said
having all of the people that are
representing this film here together in
so many different ways it felt like a
very important moment especially how the
Osage Community embraced us telling this
story it was a beautiful moment it's and
I just took a lot of mental pictures it
was something that I'm never never gonna
forget as far as taking risks at this
age what else can I do
no let's go do something comfortable are
you kidding kidding comfortable like
sitting comfortable on a set in the heat
you might as well be risking you know